while the Pricewaterhouse man is
guarding the envelopes we thought maybe
we we ought to have some custodians for
the Oscars so for the first part of the
show miss Janet Lee and mr. Don Murray
have drawn the assignment as Oscar
sitters
Jimmy genin I've been talking this over
backstage we just got to know exactly
what our duties are going to be that's
right as we understand it were to keep
our eyes on the Oscars mm-hmm that's
right and remember prize water will keep
his eye on you okay we practice the
behaviors on the first award this
evening will be for the Best Supporting
Actor and it'll be presented by a lady
who is herself candidate for the best
actress award of the year miss Lana
Turner
thank you so much Wow Oh what are we
gonna leave please
Oh why are you nervous no it's just that
I like you oh well now I'm nervous the
Best Supporting Actor nominees are red
buttons sayonara vittorio de sica
farewell to arms says you Hayakawa the
Bridge on the River Kwai Arthur Kennedy
Peyton Place and Russ Tamblyn Peyton
Place and the winner is red button
thank you ladies and gentlemen
I'm very grateful I'm very thankful like
to thank Marty Baum
Bill Gates Marlon Brando and most of all
Josh Logan for that faith in me I'm very
happy I thank you very much